well it's time for another gpu launch
and i know it's probably going through
your minds right now
this is yet again another graphics card
that i just can't buy
i mean we'll just have to wait and see
what the stock situation is like for the
rtx 3060
and i'm just gonna cross my fingers and
hope that the miracle
happens anyways just like our last gpu
reviews this video isn't going to be
a typical performance overview i'm sure
there's going to be plenty of them out
there on the internet
but i will be focusing on our usual
benchmarks but i also want to talk about
what an
upgrade path would look like for someone
who is hanging on to
an older card you see the simple fact is
a lot of folks
with 60 series cards just skipped over
the rtx 2060s
and with good reason too i mean even
more than four years
after it was released the gtx 1060 is
still
the number one in the steam hardware
charts but now with the rtx
3060 it might finally be time to step up
but i also wanted to take
a further step back by also talking
about
what this means for you guys who are
still rocking a gtx 960
or a gtx 970. so if you like this
approach please let me know in the
comments down below but first
a quick message from our sponsor
productivity is choosing to get things
done on time and finding the right tool
for the right task is important
you want a display that's big enough to
accommodate your content but also color
accurate to put a smile on your face
build quality that defines exceptional
craftsmanship but
also light enough to accommodate you
during travel performance that speeds up
your workflow
with intel's 11th gen core series
processors and the battery life that
lasts you for an entire day
thanks to intel's evo certification
along with flexible connectivity like
thunderbolt 4 and hdmi
to expand your lifestyle meet the razer
book 13
the ultimate productivity laptop alright
before getting the benchmarks let's take
care of some house cleaning business and
bring you guys up to speed
about what the rtx 3060 is all about
it's significantly cut down from the rtx
3060 ti
but i guess that's expected since it
costs 70 dollars less
the question is whether or not those
cuts went too deep
but at least board power is only around
170 watts
one interesting thing is the 192 bit bus
meant either six gigabytes or 12
gigabytes of memory with amd's current
and upcoming cards rocking huge memory
sizes
nvidia really couldn't have this go down
to six gigabytes so the rtx 360
has more memory than the rtx 3080 with a
starting price of 330
there's no doubt that demand will be way
higher than supply even though nvidia is
using
algorithm detection to cut ethereum
mining hash rates
in half and i want to jump onto that
right away because nvidia is claiming
that they're cutting mining performance
on the rtx 360 to get this gpu into the
hands of more gamers
that plan might work but there are two
problems that i see with this
first is that they're actually
penalizing gamers who want to
mine with their gpu in their spare time
and second even at half the speed
this gpu is still going to be turning
profit in under a year so
i don't think this short term solution
will really do all that much so with
that out of the way let's talk about the
evga card that i'll be using here
since this gpu is supposed to hit that
sweet uh 330
msrp technically without crazy retailer
markups now this is a pretty compact
eight inch gpu with a dual slot heatsink
a single eight pin power input and
thankfully it's not one of those crazy
designs evg has been pumping out lately
all in all
it looks like a good in-place
replacement or upgrade for literally any
chassis and
that's important since some of the other
360 cards that i've been seeing
are ginormous but i guess the most
important thing that we need to set here
is a baseline to see how this card
actually performs against
other current generation gpus and to do
that we're using our usual test system
sporting the amd
5900x and since this card's meant to
bridge the 1080p and 1440p performance
spaces
both of those resolutions will be tested
so let's get through this i'm going to
throw in some background music and feel
free to pause
if you want to look at a particular or a
specific result
[Music]
okay so let's put this into a bit
clearer perspective by looking at some
averages
overall at 1080p the rtx 3060 writes the
gap
right between the rtx 2060 super and the
rtx 2070 super
which is about what we'd expect remember
the rtx 360 ti took over from the rtx
2060 super
at the 400 price point and it's a good
30 faster but the 30 60 to 20 60 gap is
about 20
so it's not all that much and that's
going to be a bit of a letdown but
it's also not like every rtx 2060 user
is going to look into upgrade to the rtx
and they shouldn't at 1440p it's pretty
much the same too and i've got to admit
it came as a bit of a disappointment
since we're so used to the 3000 series
delivering such
massive uplifts versus the previous
generation but then again
it's also important to remember that the
360 costs a good 20
less than the 2060 did when it was
launched so there's that but looking at
things
from a value perspective the rtx 3060
delivers consistently good frame rates
for its price there's a super obvious
linear increase here as well
you pay 20 more for the 360 ti and get
about 20 percent more performance
period also remember that we're going
with launch prices and not the inflated
madness that we're seeing right now
uh so basically what i'm trying to say
is everything that i just mentioned
right now gets thrown out of the window
if you end up overpaying for your gpu
which nobody should meanwhile ray
tracing performance is closer to the rtx
2070 super which
was pretty much expected given the
updates with second generation rt cores
performance isn't anywhere near regular
rasterization but at least
there's a way to check out what all the
fuzz is about at
playable frame rates by using the ga 106
core nvidia's actually been able to cut
down power consumption
by quite a bit when compared to the rtx
3060 ti
at least on the average consumption side
but there's more to it than that
especially if you're looking to upgrade
an
older system that might not have a super
modern power supply and that's where rtx
cards
might cause a few headaches for gtx 900
and thousand series owners
especially if you look at the peak power
number on this evga card
if you have a good 500 watt psu then you
should be just fine
but these numbers need to be taken into
account before just assuming
an rtx 3060 is a drop drop-in upgrade
also don't forget that
most if not all rtx 360 cards need an
8-pin connector
and they don't come with an adapter and
not all psus from
years ago come with one so that could be
an additional expense so i guess that
brings me to the part that i'm sure a
lot of you skip to
it's time to talk about the upgrade path
for these cards
what kind of performance can you expect
well we used
the exact same system as before and
brought a few cards out of retirement so
that includes the gtx 1066 gigabyte
a gtx 970 and finally a gtx
960. now this lineup led both mike and i
into a conversation about
price grip of nvidia's 60 series cards
today the rtx 360
is being launched at 330 dollars us
which might not seem like a lot when
compared to the overpriced
rtx 2060 but if you're coming from a gtx
1060 six gigabyte from
four years ago man it's a whole lot more
to pay and if you compare that to the
gtx 960s
200 launch price i think it drives that
point home
even more the rtx 3060 is in a whole
other price range as a matter of fact
that's the same street price as the gtx
970 when that was launched so now that
the stage has been set
let's go through this starting at 1080p
also remember that these results were
run
at the highest detail levels so just
remember turning down some of the
settings
will actually allow some of the older
cards to perform better either way it's
pretty obvious that the gtx 960 simply
can't keep up
with the other cards mostly because of
its 2 gigabyte memory size which
actually locks it out of playing some
games at our settings
the gtx 970 is pretty impressive given
its age
and it's a bit of a fair comparison to
the rtx 360.
both launched at the same price of 330
and even though the 970 ended up being a
super controversial card
it's hard to complain about how well
it's holding up but the older cards do
still handle themselves pretty well in
online shooters
by delivering a perfectly playable
experience but ultra high frame rates do
give a competitive advantage in fps
games i have to say though that gtx 1060
it's such an impressive card at 1080p
and you can see why people are still
hanging onto them
but while the move from it to the rtx
2060 was tough to justify
the 360 gets almost exactly double the
performance
moving away from 1080p to 1440p shows
where the real advantages
for the newer cards are especially with
the new rtx 360.
if you're still sitting at 1080p the gtx
960 might be showing its age but
that's nothing a few lower settings
won't fix if you want to make a jump to
a high resolution monitor though
it's just not going to cut it the gtx
970 fares a lot better
even with its odd memory layout of not
quite four gigabytes but even then
jumping up to an rtx 360 would give a
night and day difference in visuals
and frame rates the funny thing is even
here the 1060 proves
why it was one of the best gpus and
videos ever produced
it's aged like fine wine but it does
tend to run
out of steam in some games here it's a
laser targeted 1080p gaming card whereas
the rtx 3060 is a lot more versatile for
wider range of resolutions
on the flip side there's just no way i'd
upgrade from
an rtx 2060 to this card the benefits
are just not worth it so the rtx 3060
delivering
such high results against older cards on
a modern system
i'm sure a lot of you guys are probably
wondering uh what happens when you
simply drop this thing into an existing
pc
would there be a cpu bottleneck or not
well
we've got you covered here as well with
a pretty upper
mid-level system right out of 2015 and
something which
might have been paired up with a gtx 970
or 960. i already covered the cpu
bottleneck on higher end rtx 3000 gpus
and you can check out that video right
up here in this corner
so these results were pretty much
expected at higher detail settings even
at 1080p
you will be giving up some performance
for this gpu especially
in online shooters but move to 1440p
which moves even more low to the gpu
and the gap narrows even further so
until the supply of new processors
improves
at least you can get a nice upgrade
while you wait for a larger
system upgrade well i guess that's
pretty much everything that i wanted to
cover in this video
and i think my conclusion is pretty
obvious rtx 2060 owners
there's absolutely no reason to upgrade
to the rtx 3060.
this card isn't for you the rtx 3060
caters to the usual mid-range gpu
upgrade cycle
between three to four years people in
this price bracket
just aren't looking to jump to a new
card every other year and in that case
it does pretty well but please just
don't end up paying scalper prices
for one so that note thank you so much
watching
i hope you were able to take away
something from this video
but uh yeah stay safe
and spend responsibly